During this course, you'll complete a variety of different kind of assessments.
These assessments play different roles.
First, they help you learn by demonstrating and
testing what you know. Second, they help you reflect on what you've learned.
Third, they help us understand what material is being taught well,
and what is not being taught well. The main assessment of the projects. You'll
complete a series of programming projects in designing AI agents that address
a pretty complex task. We'll talk a little bit more about it in a few minutes.
Second, written assignments. We'll compete a number of written assignments that
will tie the course material to the projects. Third, tests. There will be
two tests in this class using the content of this class to introduce a broad
variety of problems. Fourth, exercises. Throughout the lessons there'll be
a number of exercises to help you evaluate and manage your own learning. Fifth,
interactions. We'll be looking at the interactions of the forum and other places
to get a feel for how everyone is doing and how can we help improve learning